This episode of Real Engineering was brought
to you by Skillshare, home to over 16,000
classes that could teach you a new life skill.
The first 500 people to sign up with the link
the description will get a 2 month free trial.
On a cold and stormy morning in January 1953,
the Princess Victoria ferry was preparing
to leave its dock in Stranraer on the south-west
coast of Scotland, despite gale warnings.
An hour into its journey its captain radioed
for help as the storm forced the ferry on
its side, making it impossible to board the
lifeboats.
Of the 176 people aboard the princess victoria,
only 43 survived, but there was more tragedy
to come, this storm was headed south towards
the Netherlands, pushing the seas with it,
and with the Moon and Sun causing even higher
tides, this storm would severely test the
flood defences of the Netherlands, which was
still getting back on its feet after the Second
World War.
The storm would ultimately claim the lives
of 1,835 people in the Netherlands, along
with 200,000 cattle and flooding 2,000 square
kilometres of land, destroying 43,000 homes
forcing and 72,000 people to flee.
Today, we are going to learn why this happened
and how it would spark the construction of
one of the seven modern wonders of the world:
The Dutch Delta Works.
After World War 2, the meandering levees on
the coast of the Netherlands had fallen into
disrepair, the Netherlands were just getting
back onto their feet after 5 years German
occupation just 8 years prior to the storm.
The poorly maintained flood defences were
a disaster waiting to happen.
As the storm approached, it forced water inlands
with no-where to go, but up.
This put intense pressure on the dykes and
levees of the low countries, and by the storm’s
end 139 kilometres of levees would be heavily
damaged, with holes up to 3.5 kilometres being
torn open.
With nearly 26% of the Netherlands land area
being under sea level, seawater burst through
these breeches with immense strength causing
damage that would take decades to repair and
would spur the formation of the Delta Committee
just 20 days later to ensure this could never
happen again and this is what they came up
with.
The new Delta plan would shorten the Dutch
coastline by 700 kilometres, by closing the
primary inlets in these 4 locations, this
would drastically reduce the length of levees
and dykes that needed to be inspected and
maintained and thus decreasing the chances
of weak points jeopardising the safety of
the Dutch people.
However this was no easy task and would come
with an enormous cost.
Before these works could be completed, additional
barriers needed to be erected upstream to
improve fresh and saltwater management, and
prevent fresh water emptying from the Rhine,
Meuse and Schelde river from redirecting around
these new dams.
The northern most closure dam also needed
to be equipped with a hydraulic sluice capable
of dealing with the output of the Rhine river,
as this Fresh water would flood the Netherlands
from the other direction, if it was prevented
from emptying into the North Sea.
On top of all this, a number of ports, such
as the port of Rotterdam and the port of Antwerp,
had to stay accessible.
So, aside from fixed dams, bridges and sluices,
two new locks that would allow an inland ship
route between Antwerp and Rotterdam needed
to be built.
Amazingly, on top of all this work, the dutch
still managed to consider the environmental
impact of this work.
The largest of the structures built for the
Delta Works project, the Oosterschelde Storm
Surge Barrier, was originally planned to completely
close the mouth of this river, which would
create a fresh water basin.
However resistance to this plan arose, as
it would completely change the saltwater environment
of the area.
The Oosterschelde scenery is unique, with
a great variety of fish, water plants and
animals.
So in 1976 the Dutch government agreed to
a different plan: Building an open barrier
that could be closed during heavy storms and
high tides.
adding another 2.5 billion euros to the cost
to the project.
This barrier is 9 kilometres long with 62
openings, each 40 metres wide, allowing the
tidal movement to remain in tact.
To build a structure this massive, that needs
to not only support it’s own weight, but
the enormous force of a storm surge pushing
against it, would require extensive foundations.
The first part of these foundations were created
by forming two islands, the biggest of which
housing a lock to allowing ships to pass through
the barrier.
This island even included a massive dry dock
to construct the 65 pylons needed to support
the sluice gates, each using 7,000 cubic metres
of concrete and taking one-and-a-half years
to build.
Between each island a trench was dug.
On both sides of the trench, mats were placed
to keep the seabed in place.
While specially built ships were then used
to consolidate the sand at the bottom of the
trench, using special vibrating needles, the
sand would be vibrated to pack the sand firmly
together creating a surface that could carry
the weight of the massive pylons.
The trench itself was then covered with specially
made mats filled with rocks to help prevent
erosion of the underlying sand.
The pylons were left hollow so they could
be picked up by another purpose-built, u-shaped
ship, and moved into place.
There, inside the trench, on top of the mats,
they would be lowered, filled with sand and
closed with concrete.
The wide foot of each pylon was packed in
stone, as it is vital the pylons never move,
because if even one of the massive, 260 to
480 tonne doors, cannot move, the current
in that location could become enormous and
potentially damage the structure.
Finally these enormous hydraulic pistons were
attached to the sluice gates, allowing 3 kilometres
of the 9 kilometre long Storm Surge Barrier
to open and close on demand.
This project truly is one of the modern wonders
of the world.
Allowing the dutch to rule the tide and ensure
the chances of another devastating flood are
dramatically reduced, but with sea levels
continuing to rise and warmers seas causing
even stronger storms, we need to remind ourselves
of the lessons learned here.
The flooding of New Orleans in 2005 occurred
for many of the same reasons as the 1953 flooding
of the Netherlands.
Poorly maintained levees broke well below
their design tolerances, allowing 80% of the
city to be flooded in just 5 hours.
Had New Orleans taken lessons from history
and reduced the length of defences needed,
as they have done now with the 1.1 billion
dollar Lake Borgne Surge Barrier, they may
have saved of over 1000 people and prevented
the 108 billion dollars of damage the storm
caused.
If these trends continue cities around the
world are going to have to seriously assess
the risk of flooding and make plans to prevent
any chance of a flood taking the lives of
their citizens.
So you may admired some of the footage in
this video, it’s not the first I have travelled
to a location to get footage, but it is the
first time I have really felt prepared because
I finally learned the necessary skills to
use my equipment like a professional from
Skillshare.
I learned all the technical terms and settings
to set up still shots of the storm surge barrier.
I learned how to get cinematic shots with
my drone and I learned how to apply the correct
colour corrections too.
Skillshare is simply the best place on the
internet to learn creative skills that could
help you develop a new life skill.
With professional and understandable classes,
that follow a clear learning curve.
You could even learn the skills to start a
new business like I did for this channel,
through courses for animation and editing.
A Premium Membership begins around $10 a month
for unlimited access to all courses, but the
first 500 people to sign up with this link
will get a 2 month free trial.
In those 2 months you could easily learn the
skills you need to start a new hobby or business.
So ask yourself right now.
What skill have you been putting off learning.
What project have you been dreaming of completing,
but you aren’t sure if you have the skills
to do it.
Why not start right now and sign up to Skillshare
using the link below.
You have nothing to lose and a valuable life
skill to gain.
As usual, thank you for watching and thank
you to all my patreon supporters for helping
this channel exist.
If you would like to see more from me or see
more content from Real Engineering, like sneak
peeks for upcoming videos, check out the links
for Instagram, twitter and facebook accounts
in the description.